we often talk about what happens when
parents burden their kids with their
possessions but today we need to talk
about what it looks like when kids force
their parents to hold on to all of their
childhood stuff
[Music]
one more talk aboutable for you here
we often talk about what happens when
parents burden their kids with their
possessions but today we need to talk
about what it looks like when kids force
their parents to hold on to all of their
childhood stuff oh boy take a look at
this video
what do you mean it all has to be gone
you don't know what it's like out there
there's no room for this stuff in my
place I can't part with it I don't know
how to part with it look at this mug
that's me Mom I love it I'm taking it a
lot of this stuff is like I don't want
it to live with me but I wanted to stay
with you up in here you want to make
this a yoga room when did you do yoga
show me a downward dog this is like my
stuff look at my championship basketball
Jack and this is exhausting this is
traumatic these books are like important
to me I don't have room for that but
they're important to me I don't have it
in me to go through the bins under the
bed not the Beanie Babies there's just
things that have to say here this is
their home no I'm gonna be ruthless here
throw that away just throw that away now
you're gonna feel nostalgic look at
these pictures I don't even know who
these people are you can't do anything
if I stay here
a Beanie Baby
so isn't this fascinating what we I
don't want to be burdened by this stuff
but TK I don't mind if you're burdened
by the stuff oh man you know what if we
personalize things like this and and I
said hey man you're important to me but
I don't have time to sit here and listen
to you talk about your day you're
important to me but I don't have any
energy to help you with anything that
you need help with yeah you're important
to me but I'm not going to spend any of
my money buying you a cup of coffee yeah
you're important to me I'm not going to
introduce you to anybody that I know at
some point while it is totally
acceptable for you to say I can't do
these things at some point it becomes
fair to say hey in what sense of the
word important am I important to you
right I like some positive conception of
that and so we can say that about all
these things but this is important to me
these Beanie Babies this old
Championship jacket it's important to me
but I'm not willing to pay the price
of saying it's important I'm not willing
to take it and carry it with me I'm not
willing to bring it in my home take
responsibility for maintaining it and
storing it and I think this is a a
really funny illustration of something
that doesn't get questioned enough and I
think a lot of us are guilty off there's
something about your parents in the
house you grew up in that kind of makes
you feel entitled to using that place as
a storage facility I mean I've still got
some things in my parents house that if
they were to call me out and say hey you
need to come get this I would probably
say throw it away but I'm not motivated
to call them and say Hey you can go get
rid of that I'm not motivated the next
time I go home to throw it out on my own
or give it away on my own because I'm
not paying the price for it yeah and by
the way if your parents want to hold on
to these things that's one thing but as
Illustrated perfectly in this Tick Tock
video what you see is like the parents
want their space back we raise you for
18 or 20 or however many years can we
get our space back now can you get your
clutter because it's clutter to them and
it may not be cluttered to you although
you've identified and said actually it
is clutter to me this happened to me
when I was dealing with my mom's stuff I
had to pack up all three houses worth of
stuff that were crammed in her tiny one
bedroom apartment when I was sorting
through her things when she died and I
was going to take it all back to my
house but I realized I couldn't go
mingle my mom's stuff with my stuff
because I already had a big house in a
full basement full of stuff and so I
couldn't marry her stuff and my stuff so
what did I do I got a storage locker
because I couldn't keep it in that same
apartment because she was gone now right
and we do that with our things it's not
really that important to me but it's
important enough for me to burden you
with it because I don't want to burden
myself with it
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]